a successful marriage requires falling
in love many times always with the same
person
when you realize you want to spend the
rest of your life with somebody you want
the rest of your life to start as soon
as possible
[Music]
love doesn't just sit there like a stone
it has to be made like bread remade all
the time
a great marriage is not when a perfect
couple comes together it is when an
imperfect couple learns to enjoy their
differences
there's no more lovely friendly and
Charming relationship than a good
marriage
a happy marriage is a long conversation
that always seems too short
people are weird when we find someone
with weirdness that is compatible with
ours we team up with them and call it
love
love does not consist of gazing at each
other but in looking outward together in
the same direction
to love and be loved is to feel the Sun
from both sides
I love being married it's so great to
find that one special person you want to
annoy for the rest of your life
what we have once enjoyed we can never
lose all that we love deeply becomes a
part of us
a marriage doesn't have to be perfect
but you can be perfect for each other
happy is the marriage where the husband
is the head and the wife is the heart
marriage is not a tight knot but a slip
knot
marriage is a sack full of 99 snakes and
one kneel
marriage is a covered dish
men have thought about their marriage a
whole year long and it lasts but one
night
marriage is a little bit like buying
melons you need some luck
a second marriage is like a warmed up
meal
better a good hanging than a bad
marriage
the first marriage is a plate of Honey
the second a glass of wine the third is
a cup of poison
[Music]
marriage is the opposite of a fever
attack it begins hot and ends cold
marriage is a snake to slip into your
handbag
to have a beautiful servant girl is a
threat to a good marriage
age and marriage tame the Beast
no marriage contract is made without a
quarrel
marriages are not as they are made but
as they turn out
which is like a besieged fortress those
who are outside want to come in and
those already in want to get out
marriage has teeth and it bites hard
love is a sweet dream and marriage is
the alarm clock
marriage is like a ground nut you have
to crack it to see what's inside
marriage halves are Greaves doubles our
Joys and quadruples our expenses
marriage is a lottery in which men stake
their Liberty and women their happiness
a perfect marriage is one in which I'm
sorry is said just often enough
one should never know too precisely whom
one has married
there is no more lovely friendly and
Charming relationship communion or
company than a good marriage
marriage is the alliance of two people
one of which never remembers birthdays
and the other never forgets them
[Music]
marriage is a bribe to make the
housekeeper think she's a householder
[Music]
marriage is three parts love and seven
Parts forgiveness of sins
long engagements give people the
opportunity of finding out each other's
character before marriage which is never
advisable
married life teaches one invaluable
lesson to think of things far enough
ahead not to say them
any intelligent woman who reads the
marriage contract and then goes into it
deserves all the consequences
it is not marriage but people that fail
all that marriage does is reveal people
women hope men will change after
marriage but they don't men hope women
won't change but they do
happiness in marriage is entirely a
matter of chance
The Secret of a happy marriage remains a
secret
as to marriage or celibacy let a man
take which course he will he will be
sure to repent
it takes a loose Reign to keep a
marriage tight
a long marriage is two people trying to
dance a duet and two solos at the same
time
it's a funny thing that when a man
hasn't anything on Earth to worry about
he goes off and gets married
marriage is an alliance entered into by
a man who can't sleep with the window
shut and a woman who can't sleep with it
open
marriage is our last best chance to grow
up
Love is Blind but marriage restores its
sight
the highest happiness on Earth is
marriage
[Music]
I've always considered marriage as the
most interesting event of one's life the
foundation of happiness or misery
the chief reason why marriage is rarely
a success is that it is contracted while
the partners are insane
more marriages might survive if the
partners realize that sometimes the
better comes after the worse
marriage is a mistake every man should
make
many marriages are simply working
Partnerships between businessmen and
housekeepers
Love and Marriage Love and Marriage go
together like a horse and carriage dad
was told by mother you can't have one
without the other
success in marriage does not come merely
through finding the right mate but
through being the right mate
marriage is not a word it is a sentence
after a few years of marriage a man can
look right at a woman without seeing her
and a woman can see right through a man
without looking at him
marriage is that relation between man
and woman in which the independence is
equal the dependence mutual and the
obligation reciprocal
what counts in making a happy marriage
is not so much how compatible you are
but how you deal with incompatibility
like good wine marriage gets better with
age once you learn to keep a cork on it
men should keep their eyes wide open
before marriage and half shut afterwards
some marriages break up some do not you
can usually explain the former but not
the latter
a first-rate marriage is like a
first-rate hotel expensive but worth it
love requires a willingness to die
marriage a willingness to live
the value of marriage is not that adults
produce children but the children
produce adults
though marriage makes man and wife one
flesh it leaves them two fools
marriage is a book of which the first
chapter is written in poetry the
remaining chapters in prose
[Music]
marriage is not a noun it's a verb it
isn't something you get it's something
you do it's the way you love your
partner every day
marriage is like pleading guilty to an
indefinite sentence without parole
the difficulty with marriage is that we
fall in love with a personality but must
live with a character
marriage must constantly fight against a
monster that devours everything routine
no man expects a great deal from
Marriage he is quite satisfied if his
wife is a good cook a good ballet
unattentive audience and a patient nurse
the happiest marriage I can imagine
would be the union of a deaf man with a
blind woman
of all actions of a man's life his
marriage does least concern other people
yet of all actions of our life it is
most meddled with by other people
if you want to read about love and
marriage you've got to buy two separate
books
one of the best things about marriage is
that it gets young people to bed at a
decent hour
the music at a marriage procession
always reminds me of the music of
soldiers entering battle
often the difference between a
successful marriage and a mediocre one
consists of leaving three or four things
a day unsaid
when marrying ask yourself this question
do you believe that you will be able to
converse well with this person into your
old age
everything else in marriage is
transitory
they say a person needs just three
things to be truly happy
someone to love something to do and
something to hope for
The Secret of a happy marriage is
finding the right person you know
they're right if you love to be with
them all the time
a woman who has not been twice married
cannot know what a perfect marriage is
the song which two married people owed
to one another devise calculation it is
an infinite debt which can only be
discharged through eternity
for two people in a marriage to live
together day after day is unquestionably
the one Miracle the Vatican has
overlooked
in every marriage more than a week old
there are grounds for divorce the trick
is to find and continue to find grounds
for marriage
okay